tous ensemble déterminé à ne rien lâcher
le cso extraordinaire a laissé de
nombreuses questions en suspens quant à
l'avenir de la papeterie
l'offre de reprise qui a été acceptée
par upm
le groupe finlandais propriétaire du
site aucun ici ne la comprend elle
prévoit un démantèlement du site qui est
unique en france pour à la place ya
installé une unité de production
d'hydrogène pour les syndicats
impossible de laisser passer ça d'autant
que grâce à leur mobilisation
une offre pape et yelle est sur la table
mais pour qu'elle aboutisse
ils ont besoin de temps on a demandé à
l'état à bercy au ministère de
l'industrie yacht de jouer leur rôle de
prendre publiquement une position sur
chapelle darblay de facilité de prendre
position et de faciliter une industrie
papetière redémarrage industriel pas
petit sur chapelle darblay notre accord
est tombé le 30 juin 2021 non les
positions
les salariés et syndicats ont réussi à
mobiliser de nombreux acteurs dans leur
lutte
philippe martinez secrétaire général de
la cgt la mère de grand-couronne
plusieurs ong comme greenpeace ou encore
le président du ceser le conseil
économique social et environnemental
régional
pour ce dernier le projet hydrogène n'a
rien à faire sur ce site
le ceser après position en faveur
suite à une sollicitation d'ailleurs des
représentants du personnel de chapelle
darblay position pour que cette
entreprise soins reprise mais dans le
cadre de la filière papetière et
singulièrement avec sa spécificité de
traitement et de valorisation des
déchets papiers cartons l'offre
papetière mis sur la table par les
syndicats éviterait non seulement un
démantèlement du site mais permettrait
surtout de conserver un savoir faire
unique en france de sauver en somme
toute une économie circulaire pour les
syndicats et représentants cadre ce
qu'il manque c'est une réelle prise de
position de la part des pouvoirs publics
mais qu'est ce qui bloque c'est la
volonté de porter un projet papier on
nous a toujours on devait toujours
ailleurs cantonné dans cette offre
papetière mais qui est parti ailleurs
finalement en ne portant aucun crédit à
d'autres à d'autres projets sauf que
cette heure papetière elle est partie
elle est partie sans ses partenaires et
les partenaires qui se sont trouvés
plantés ont décidé de revenir avec nous
depuis le 30 juin dernier le
démantèlement du site peut donc arriver
à tout moment
de leur côté les salariés et syndicats
comptent plus que jamais sur l'état